PAIGE SCHOENING:
And first I'd like
to start from the very
beginning with you used to work
in Silicon Valley in robotics.
How did you make
the switch to tea?
What was it about tea
that really grabbed you?
NED HEAGERTY: Well, first
let me say thank you
for the opportunity to be here.
I think as a tea
person, we're always
pleased to have the
opportunity to talk tea
with an American audience.
It's an educative
process, if you will.
So I'll try and make it
as interesting as possible
because certainly tea has
been an interesting, I would
call it, adventure for me.
Well, like many people, I
had practical constraints
on my life--
children in college, a
home, [? food ?] to be,
and all of that.
I had become quite tired
of business as I knew it.
And also a horrific commute
every day was weighing heavily
on me.
So I made the decision that
I would find a new business.
And a mutual friend
approached me and said,
there's this wonderful tea
company and a very interesting
man who's looking for
a partner or someone
to take over his business.
And that was my introduction
to David Lee Hoffman,
who was the founder
of Silk Road Teas.
And I should give David a
moment here because it's
a very interesting story, as he
is arguably the first American
that traveled in
China extensively
long before the market
was really open for tea.
It was actually
restricted to many areas.
You could not travel in
China to these areas.
And David took it upon
himself to do that
and single-handedly broke new
territory for the specialty tea
industry as we know it today.
David left the United States
as a graduate student.
He didn't finish his education.
Frustrated, he left
the United States
and traveled the world for close
to 10 years, ending in Asia.
And of course,
most of that time,
like the rest of the
world, drank tea--
but was particularly taken
with the tea in China,
and brought home tea of
course when he eventually
came back after
10 years of travel
without coming back
to the United States,
and introduced some
friends to the Chinese tea.
And in a classic sort of
business beginning, they said,
wow, can you get
some of this for me?
And of course, the proverbial
light bulb goes off.
He starts a tea company
and begins to import tea.
And albeit, it was in very
small increments at that point.
Again, like I said,
he actually could not
get into certain areas of China.
It was not open
yet for commerce.
And the tea industry
was quite protective
also in China, the government.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Right.
When he first went,
wasn't it kind of taboo
to buy direct from tea farms?
NED HEAGERTY: Correct.
Yeah.
The government really liked to
channel that, as did the tea--
the nascent, the
beginning tea companies.
As it was beginning, you're
seeing the very beginnings
of China beginning to
decentralize certainly
the tea industry.
It was totally, at one time,
run by the Chinese government.
Certainly ownership of
the specialty tea farms
were largely owned by--
anyone that was
processing the tea--
the tea farmers were
quite alone and separate,
but the processing of the
tea was being handled largely
by the government.
So he had to go
into that territory.
And David had the good fortune
to meet a couple of gentlemen
early on who had studied
tea in university
and were working
for large companies,
but I think must have
had a bit of the hope
that they could get
into the US market
and so traveled with David into
these back areas to buy tea.
They quickly understood
that it wasn't
going to be the kinds
of dollar volumes
I think that they had hoped.
Their management
really asked them
to back off and
try and get David
to conform more to buying
in traditional channels.
David didn't want to do that.
And fortunately, a couple
of those individuals
decided that they would truncate
their current employment
and break out on their own and
sort of freelance, if you will,
or broker in the business.
And those early on people,
like Mr. Song, today
is my partner in China.
He's the person that handles
most of my business affairs
on China's side.
And it underscores in
China, I think at the level
when you talk about
specialty teas,
that it's about relationships,
like so many things in Asia.
Over time, you develop a
trust and an understanding
of what tea quality is or
what you're looking for.
And you constantly
revisit that concept.
But it's there, and it builds.
And over time, you
begin to understand
what you're both
looking for and what
works for the relationship.
And you can get some very
interesting tea as a result.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Right.
And what was it
like when you first
traveled with him to China
to specifically buy tea?
And I'm curious
because I saw-- there's
a documentary "All in This
Tea" that kind of went
with him to buy tea in China.
One of the shots was he
arrives in this village,
and people are just coming
up to him with bags of tea,
asking them to smell his tea.
Were you guys getting mobbed
like that when you first
went to China with him?
NED HEAGERTY: Yeah, you do.
You get a lot of offers,
a lot of freelance offers.
It depends where
you are, of course.
But I do remember the first
few trips to China with David.
It was interesting because
I realized from this side,
I looked at tea and I thought,
well, what a wonderful product.
Even back-- this would be 2001,
2002 is when I'm first meeting
David--
I'm already looking
at tea and saying,
tea really has a great future.
There's an aging
population here.
There's the health benefits.
There's certainly
a culture that's
looking for some diversity.
People are appreciating
quality increasingly.
So all the trends were there.
But it still is here and there.
And so my concern
was, how do I validate
that I can do what David did?
Is this a doable business model?
Because I'll qualify,
I'm a tea trader.
I sell tea.
That's my business.
I'm not in the business
of the ceremony
or necessarily the
cultural side of it.
I sell tea.
But I recognize at the same
time that that's a relationship.
It was my understanding of Asia
from prior business in Asia
that it was very much
based on relationships.
So when we went to
China the first time,
we actually gathered
all of the key suppliers
that we could identify,
which was about eight people
from various provinces in China,
easily six different provinces.
And we all gathered in the
city of Fuzhou along the coast
and spent a weekend together--
essentially just visiting,
and talking about tea, tasting
tea, taking hikes, eating food.
And that was sort of--
that was my first introduction.
And it's a cast of characters--
Mr. Song, Mr. [? Square, ?] Mr.
[? Chen Fin, ?] [? Chen Lu. ?]
So there's a group, and
that group's pretty much
remained intact with
some new players always.
But that initial weekend
and then travel in China
was sort of--
it confirmed for me
that it would work,
that this was a way-- that
model that David had could work.
It needed some work
on the business side.
It needed to become a little
more practical, if you will,
a little more focused on what
markets exactly we could supply
and what we couldn't
do and refined.
But the essential
model was there.
Particularly that it
was specialty tea,
high-grade teas, unusual
teas that I really
felt the US market was ready
for, was interested in.
And I think over time
that's proven true.
PAIGE SCHOENING:
And so you spent
a lot of time cultivating
these relationships.
What's it like when you go now?
What's it like to work with--
Mr. Song, correct?
NED HEAGERTY: Mr. Song.
PAIGE SCHOENING: So does he
set up places and times for you
to meet with folks?
Or if you could just
describe how that works.
NED HEAGERTY:
Well, to an extent,
I think because we do
business in roughly six
to seven provinces we'll
draw from every year,
with emphasis on certain
provinces for a larger
share of our tea, of course--
but through our specialty teas,
we'll go into a particular
province to secure.
So generally speaking, the
way we approach it is we
believe that the best
teas are early spring
when the plant's fully alive.
It's coming out of
the winter dormancy.
And all of that
vibrant growth is
going up into the
leaf and bud, always
in that endless
pursuit of procreation.
But that bud and those
first three leaves
are wonderful teas at
that time of the year.
The flavors are very nuanced.
They're vibrant.
The leaves are
tender, everything.
If you taste good
tea, that's the time.
That's the best tea there is
in the world, in my opinion.
So somewhere along the
line, like right now,
I'm beginning to
think about that.
It's early March.
Late March is when
the first teas
will start to come out in
a province like Fujian,
early whites and green teas.
So we'll begin--
I'll, latter part of
March, travel to China,
try to get there before
the 1st of April.
Hopefully if the
weather's been warm,
the first teas
will be coming out.
We'll start seeing green teas.
I'll meet Mr. Song in
Fuzhou, for example.
And then we go into the
tea market and visit
with certain people in there
that we do business with.
And I will usually have a
list or references of teas
that I've either bought prior
years that I really enjoyed
and that our customers
seemed to really enjoy
and some new things that
I might be curious for
and put that word out.
And these men channel
sort of-- they're
our conduit, if you will,
to small farms in the area.
Word goes out.
And then over the
next week or so, we
begin to see samples come in.
And we'll spend the day in
the tea market sampling tea.
That would probably
be-- early on,
it'd be the Mao Feng green
teas and variations of that.
There's just a raff of
varietals of Mao Feng now.
If it grows on the north
slope, it's one taste and look.
If it's on the south
slope, it's this.
East and West, each one-- in
each soil, the elevation--
develops over time in a
farm a different taste, just
like wine.
So we're in pursuit of that.
And here's sort of our
wish list, if you will.
And it'll go out.
So Song and I will spend time
tasting basically all day--
from early in the day
until evening tasting tea.
When we find a lot we like
that makes sense, fits,
what would you like for it?
How much is there?
What can we do?
Song then steps in and sort of
handles everything from there.
Once we've made the
purchase, procured the tea,
it will be shipped to a
warehouse where we repackage
it, get it into what we would
call high-grade packaging,
and vacuum seal it if
the leaf can handle that
or do a light vacuum, and put it
into a high-grade carton, stuff
a container, and ship it here.
And Song handles all that side.
It's not easy to get tea
out of China necessarily,
particularly when you're
collecting from various areas.
So he's extremely good at
that and has honed his skills.
So I rely heavily
on him to do that.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Right.
And it sounds very complicated.
And I'm curious to know
more about when you're
sitting there tasting teas.
How many are you
tasting in a row?
And what notes are you looking
for in the different teas?
And are you thinking
about your customers' tea
preferences or your own?
Or how does that all work?
NED HEAGERTY: Yeah, that's a--
I think it's extremely important
to think about the customer.
I've learned over time--
this'll be the 17th or 18th year
I've been to China to taste tea
and buy tea.
One thing I've learned
in that time, what I like
may not be what
my customers like.
So there's always that kind of--
that's the challenge
as a tea buyer.
You need to find
the very best tea
that you can, but
at the same moment
be mindful of, what
would my customer--
would they follow me on this?
Would they recognize this tea?
Would they appreciate this
that I'm appreciating?
Because it can be
quite expensive.
And I don't have a
secondary store to sell.
If I can't sell it, it
stays in my warehouse
and becomes an issue.
So you really do spend the day--
basically, it would be the
same set for tasting tea
as we'll use today, where
we set certain guidelines.
The water in China will
always be filtered,
and that's important.
They generally like to use water
right at boiling temperature.
So even when we're tasting
high-grade greens and whites
and other teas, it is going
to be hit with very hot water.
And some things are going
to probably be muted.
There's ways to
work around that.
And we do.
If it's a particularly
interesting tea
and very expensive, I will
have them do an extra step
of cooling the water.
But for the most
part, we'll sit down.
We'll set rules.
Water's filtered.
Water temperature's here.
We're going to use two
grams for every five
to six ounces of water.
We're going to steep
it two minutes.
And those are the ground rules.
So everything that comes
through during the day--
and literally what
happens is people
arrive, farmers will
arrive, and have tea
that they've just processed.
And it's ready for market.
Or it comes in via carrier,
or other tea shops,
or other farmers, and
cooperative representatives
come in and bring their samples.
And we'll work through them.
So we might taste anywhere
from 10 to 30 teas in a day,
doing the same process--
sitting at a table,
brewing, steeping the tea,
tasting it, and slurping it,
listening to it.
And for me, each lot is noted
and then what taste profile
I gained from it.
If there's a price,
what was the price?
All those attributes, so that
I have a long reference, pages
of notes, that I can reference
back and sometimes go back
the next day and say, I really
was interested in that lot
that we tasted yesterday.
It was lot A or
whatever we labeled it.
Is it still available?
But you work through those
teas and, in the course,
find the teas that
you like, inquire
as to quantity that's
available, pricing,
and see if you can
strike a deal for it.
And then word goes to that
farm and says, hold that lot.
Silk Road Teas is
taking that lot.
I think it's indicative of
China that there is just
a vast amount of tea that
comes out of the mountains--
particularly in an
area like Fuzhou
which, for many
years because it's
at the end of the
Min River there,
was an international port and
has a long history of tea.
It just flows down
from the mountains,
and that's an ideal location--
high mountains in the area,
great amount of rainfall.
It cools at night and
warms during the day.
So tea really enjoys
that, and grows very well,
and gets very lush.
So it's a great spot to start.
And then from there,
we work our way
to maybe the Wuyi
Mountains or sometimes
up to Fuding, a different area,
to procure different varietals
or to visit a farm we
haven't been to in a while
and see what's going on.
And you end up with some
very interesting teas.
PAIGE SCHOENING: I bet.
And so when you're in these
different places, what
are the different
provinces known for?
Are there certain areas that
are known for certain teas?
NED HEAGERTY:
Yeah, very much so.
Well, like Fujian,
for example, is widely
known for white and
green tea, and for what
I would call elegant black
teas-- such as golden monkey,
a black Mao Feng, things of that
sort, really delicious teas.
The Wuyi blacks also.
PAIGE SCHOENING: What do
you mean by elegant tea?
What's the difference
between an elegant tea
and a non-elegant
tea, or black tea?
NED HEAGERTY: Well, I think
that there's different styles.
From my perspective,
the Fujianese
like to make a black tea that
has really a wonderful mouth
taste and feel.
But then what really
is impressive to me
is how it finishes
and lingers and what
you feel like in your upper
body as you finish tasting it.
That sensation, there's an
elegance there between not only
is the leaf usually beautifully
shaped and quite small--
and the coloration is wonderful,
so there's some elegance coming
up out of that--
but then it makes me feel
that way as I taste it
and then as it finishes.
Say, for example,
an Assam from India
tends to be much more
aggressive in the mouth.
It's much stronger
in the taste feel.
They really like a lot of mouth.
So as each culture develops
their taste profile,
it sort of plays out.
And Yunnan of course in China,
the Yunnan province, that taste
comes-- it's a
different varietal.
And the flavor that they
look for is different also
and the finish.
Although, again, I
think the Chinese--
for me, it's just
a characteristic
that I carry in
mind that I think
of when I think of
China is the finish,
and how you feel as you
drink tea with people,
and then as you feel
after you've consumed.
Yeah.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Now I want to
go back to the spring harvest
because I'm very curious.
Is that-- are all tea buyers
around the world going
to China in the spring, or is it
just the specialty tea buyers?
Or are people buying
tea throughout the year?
Is this just the
special time of year?
NED HEAGERTY: Well, it's
changed a little bit over time.
That's one of the notable
differences in the buying
pattern for the US.
It used to be-- well, I should
qualify in the specialty tea
segment, which is
what we compete in
or offer teas in, that
those teas come out.
And if you don't procure
them, then they're gone.
So you're on an
annual buy basis.
That tea comes up,
comes into the market,
or is available in the
specialty tea area.
And then it's sold,
and it's gone.
What happens is that's the
specialty tea, and that's
very characteristic I believe
of the traditional Chinese tea
culture, or tea market, tea
business in that it has always
been many, many small farms.
And then each province
having special teas.
And there's a real
sense in China
like if you're in
Zhejiang province, maybe
you don't need to go to
Fujian because we have really
great green tea and white tea.
And why would you go over there?
You have it here.
But for a tea trader like
myself, or a tea purveyor,
you want to get the
best of each one.
So that necessitates
travel to cull those out.
But if you're not in that
specialty segment and not
buying smaller lots, which
is what we do-- we buy lots,
and we try and preserve them--
when you get into the larger
tea market, the export
market that's more controlled
by larger companies
and brokerage and
things of that sort,
you need to take various lots
and blend them and create
what's called a standard.
Until China became a
free market economically,
everything in the tea business
was run by a standard.
So if you wanted
Keemun 1110, every year
it would be exactly the same.
And that tea in particular is
still pretty much the same.
But all of the teas
had a standard,
and you bought to those.
But to maintain a
standard necessarily
meant you took varying
lots and combined
them to create an
appearance and taste that
fit that standard that the
export market expected.
And so that still holds true.
And in that case, you
can buy tea sequentially
across the year.
It could get difficult
because sometimes those teas--
if China's domestic market turns
on to that tea for some reason,
that's instant, huge
competition for that tea.
You suddenly can get the
word that, I'm sorry,
but no, that tea's
gone for this year.
And it would've
been the last thing
you'd expect because it's from
a large factory maybe in Yunnan.
And it's a black, and
it's always been there.
But China's starting
to drink black tea.
It gets absorbed.
So there is that--
it's becoming different
on the supply side.
But you've had a little
bit in the specialty market
where we still have to
buy that tea and commit.
And that's where I think it's
beneficial for the small farm
because they know we're
there, and we'll buy that tea.
But I think that
for the US market
has been primarily driven
by blended teas and more
standard teas.
And most US tea
companies operate
from some sort of relationship
with a tea company
in China, a tea factory,
or a broker of some kind.
So their universe
of teas is going
to be necessarily defined.
And here are your
options for the year,
and you pick one of them.
We, of course, have
said, well, we'd
like to have a wider option.
But you have to put
that time commitment in,
and that means travel for a
few weeks in China at least.
Yeah.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Wow.
And speaking of American
and Chinese markets,
how has the tea industry
changed or evolved
since you've been in it?
NED HEAGERTY: Well, I think
that certainly there's
pressure on China's side always
to respond to the market.
So for specialty teas have
become increasingly popular
in domestic market China.
Young Chinese, for example,
unlike their parents--
their parents always
drank green tea--
increasingly drink
white tea and black tea.
So the prices of white
tea and black tea
have changed dramatically
in the last few years.
And you just see more pressure.
I think also you see it
for high-grade green teas.
You might have seen many lots
and wonderful lots of something
made from a Mei Zhan
varietal in Fujian province.
You don't see so
much of that anymore
just because the pricing for
export has become very high,
so it becomes impractical
to sell it outside of China.
But the domestic market
is also there to buy it.
And they can get--
as per capita incomes
rise in China,
there is a robust market
to buy that and consume it.
And I think you're just seeing
an awakening on China's side,
just like we have to food.
It sort of trails.
As incomes rise and
education levels rise,
people look for better
food, better clothes,
better electronics.
They want those things.
So tea meets that same
criteria or change.
So pricing changes.
Availability changes.
And then you also--
as we become more stringent
or more strict, if you will--
and I realize it's
all for the better--
with organic and EU
standards and just
FDA regulations for
this side, there's
a little bit on China's
side, why would we
bother to battle that out?
We can sell it China side for
pretty much the same price,
if not even sometimes
a better price.
So you're getting a
little bit of that hedging
also in the specialty
tea markets.
So some companies a
little less interested
in doing business in the
US over the last few years.
So I thought today we'd
try some specialty teas.
And we'll go through
quickly just a survey.
You probably know
there's arguably--
or there are six
varieties of tea in China.
We're only going to discuss
five because there's
a little bit of overlap.
There's white.
There's green, oolong, black,
Pu-erh, and yellow tea.
And yellow's probably the least
known in the United States.
And that's generally
because it's
very similar to a
green tea, but it
does have an extra
steam in the process
to heighten its sweetness.
But I think that's a small
enough differential there
that we're not going
to touch on that today.
So I'd like to start
you with what I think
is indicative of our company.
It's called Drum
Mountain White Cloud.
This is a white tea.
And white teas-- why don't you,
if you'd like, just [SNIFFS]..
I should tell you,
when you buy tea,
there's three things that
you want to do with tea.
First, of course,
you look at it.
And you say, well, does
this even look interesting?
Would I want to consume this?
And let's assume that you do.
Then you want to see
what the aroma's like.
And with tea, hopefully without
getting too much up your nose,
you do a [SNIFFS] just
a quick sniff like that.
And it should hit you,
and it should tell you.
And that's the second test.
Does it smell-- is
the aroma something
that I think I'd like to taste?
And if it passes those two
steps, you're on your way.
And you do what I'm doing here.
You do the infusion,
and steep the tea,
and see in fact if it does
taste, according to you,
to be something that you'd
like to drink or buy.
So Drum Mountain White Cloud
is from Fujian province
on the coast, very
near Fuzhou, which
I mentioned earlier
is our point of entry
generally to the tea
harvest in China.
And Drum Mountain
White Cloud grows
on a mountain called Guo Shan.
Its origination
was Buddhist monks.
They cultivated it,
one, to assist them
with the caffeine in meditation.
But then it quickly
became apparent
that it was quite popular
and had commercial value.
So they began to
market it and sell it.
And so it's become quite
a popular tea actually,
probably more so on
China's side than US side.
No, we're ready.
PAIGE SCHOENING: To pour.
NED HEAGERTY: I think
we could pour those off.
Yeah, thank you.
So white tea is the
least oxidized, arguably
the most natural of teas.
It essentially gets plucked,
sorted, cleaned, if you will.
And then it's
dried, essentially.
So it's very natural, as you
can see by the leaf structure.
There's no shaping to it.
It comes straight across, pretty
much as it came off the plant.
And the silver is unopened bud.
I think it's important
at this point
to articulate another thing
about why these teas taste
the way they taste and why
it's so important to buy
the early pluck teas.
Tea plants are what you
call apical dominant.
So in other words,
you have a stem
that grows up in the
spring and shoots up.
And that's going to have
a bud at the top, a leaf,
and another leaf.
So you get that classic--
that's called a fine pluck.
That either one leaf and a
bud, two leaves and a bud, even
down sometimes to three
leaves and a bud, and up
is called the fine pluck.
For high-end
specialty teas, you're
not going any lower than that.
How does that taste?
Is it good?
It should be sweet side
and nice, soft mouthfeel.
But apical dominance--
so the plant--
in other words, larger
leaves down below
are left on the tea
bush to photosynthesize
to send energy up.
And of course, the roots
are gathering all they can
of the nutrients in the soils.
Everything's going upward to
get to procreation, if you will.
But you want to pluck
that before that bud opens
to a flower.
The flower is not
used for drinking tea,
generally speaking.
Some people drink
them, but mostly they
press that flower to
cull an oil which is used
in processing of tea leaves.
For example, with Dragon Well,
in the wok to create an oil,
the tea flower has
an oil that they
use to help lubricate
that leaf on the wok.
So white tea is generally
one of the first teas
up certainly in the spring.
And primarily in Fujian
province is where these--
this particular tea is near
Fuzhou, Ghu Shan mountain.
But then another
famous area is Fuding.
And Fuding is more known for the
Silver Needle Yinzhen and White
Peony, which we also have
here but have opted not--
but we won't taste today.
But I did want to
mention one other.
This is called White Empress.
And this gets back a little
bit to that earlier notation
about Chinese tea culture
and the small farm.
So this is made to white tea.
It's a Mei Zhan varietal,
which I mentioned earlier.
And we'll see a
thread here where
it starts with this white tea.
But it's also been made to a
green tea, which we're going
to taste, called Wild Green.
And then it ends up
also as a black tea.
So the farmer's
taken the same bud
and leaves and created three
different styles of tea.
And that's I think highly
indicative of the Chinese tea
culture, where you don't have
the large monoculture like you
do in India broad.
You do in the Darjeelings.
You have quite a bit of this
customization, if you will.
But generally, there's
a cloning going on.
And the factories get very large
and create large, large lots.
China still is very much
driven by the smaller,
specialty aspects, or tastes.
So we're going to
taste Wild Green, which
is also a local green
tea, Fujian province.
This one is also grown
very close to Fuzhou.
I'm sorry.
This is a handmade green.
As I mentioned earlier, it's
made from a varietal called
the Mei Zhan.
M-E-I Z-H-A-N is one spelling.
And I will admit in
China, these things
tend to be spelled
very often differently
and articulated differently.
Again, that's a little bit
of the localization of tea.
But in this case, this tea
is made on a small farm
by a gentleman by
the name of Mr. Wen.
And I think Mr. Wen deserves
a little bit of notation
here because Mr.
Wen for many years
was our supplier
of Jasmine Pearls.
He's an excellent
person with jasmine.
The scenting is very
difficult to do well.
Wen now is retired and
has a small tea farm.
And every year, he invites
us out to taste tea.
And he will create--
he did White Empress.
He's done the Wild Green.
And he's done the
Black Fragrance.
Those are all made from,
as I mentioned earlier,
the same pluck, if you will.
But he's made three different
styles of tea from them.
And they're very high-grade.
They're great tasting and
I think very indicative
of tea culture.
So I'm honored that
he thinks of us,
and brings us out, and
allows us to taste tea.
And they're always delicious.
He makes very small lots.
We buy enough to supply
hopefully our customer base.
We don't wholesale these teas.
These are made for our
individual customers, our tea
lovers if you will.
I think we'll try that, yeah.
I should note here
also as we go,
I realize I'm passing a
bit of information here.
But this is a traditional
Chinese tea service table.
And in China, it's
very typical I
think, generally
speaking, to brew
your tea in the gaiwan, which
is a long, long service tea
vehicle, if you will, and
then to decant to the service
pitcher at the moment where
you like the taste of the tea.
So it doesn't continue to steep.
The gaiwan is great
because, again,
when you're buying tea,
as I mentioned earlier,
you're going to look at it.
You're going to smell it.
And then you're
going to brew it.
And then it's going to
be you've poured off,
and you're now
going to taste it.
And herein is where you get
from the lid, there's the aroma.
That tells me--
I've got a glimpse
now of what this tea--
the aroma of the tea and
a little foreshadowing,
if you will, of the
taste profile of the tea.
Plus, I'm now seeing the leaf--
in this case, a very
strong leaf, deep green.
This is a classic example
of a steamed green tea
from Fujian province.
What do you think?
Reasonable?
OK.
So five or six varieties of tea.
So we have the white,
which is minimal.
It's pretty much just
natural as it's plucked.
You have green, which
is kept green by doing
a primary or preliminary--
primary's what it's usually
called-- firing to stop
the oxidization process.
And then you're making
your decision from there
about the chemical
side of it, how
you're going to process the tea
to make the flavors that you
want inherent in it.
But it's important to
stop the oxidization
process at that point, and
shape it, and then fire it.
It holds it as a green tea and
locks in the flavors and aromas
that you have decided that
you want your tea to hold.
So midway between a white
tea and, say, a Pu-erh
or a black tea is oolong
tea, which is semi-oxidized.
It's by far the most
complex of Chinese teas
and by far the most
arduous in the manufacture.
Anywhere from eight
to, say, 18 steps
may be required to
make the tea, depending
on what the tea maker
wants as an end product,
and/or the flavors that
they're looking for,
the traditions in the area.
There are generally
two oolongs in China.
There are two styles of oolong.
There's the Tieguanyin, which
is what we're tasting here,
which is principally
Fujian province.
And then there is
the Dan Cong style,
which is higher
mountain and higher fire
and is from Guangdong province.
In both cases, they
are prize teas in China
and are considered to be
the most complex in flavor.
Another-- by rattling these
leaves also you get a little--
again, you're building to
see what this taste has.
And what I've done
there is I've given it
a preliminary wash, which is
done to awaken the tea leaves.
This tea, I think it's probably
in the neighborhood of about
18 steps, considerate
of all things,
to make this tea to the
rolled format it is,
which is what-- if you
look at it closely,
it somewhat looks
like a golf club.
It usually has a little stem
off of it and a rolled ball.
So mindful of all of that
process it's been through,
you want to give
it a quick rinse
to begin the process of
unbundling that leaf,
unfurling that leaf, and letting
its flavors and aromas cut
loose.
Do we have some
hot water for this?
We need a nice--
I would recommend
with oolong tea
that we use a boiling water.
You need it to really
wake this tea up
and get those leaves opened.
It's generally held that the
first steep is for aroma.
And the second,
third, but arguably,
typically for a very high-grade
like this, a low oxidized
Tieguanyin style,
it's going to be
in the third or the fourth
steep that the aromas
and flavors really start
to come out of the leaf.
It takes about that long.
And then I would typically
steep up to seven times
before the leaf is spent.
These are going to be
quite large leaves.
Tieguanyin comes out later
than the greens and white teas.
So you have the areas, the more
inner areas of Fujian, active,
and there's lots of
green teas and white teas
and some black teas coming out.
And then about four to six weeks
later on the coast of Fujian,
the good oolongs
start to arrive.
There is-- one class
of the Tieguanyin
is called Huangjin Gui.
Many people market
it as a jade oolong.
It's a very much
smaller varietal.
It does come out
early in the spring.
But for the most part, these
higher-grade Tieguanyins,
low-oxidized, come up a
little later in the harvest.
This is a low-oxidized
Tieguanyin.
China has traditionally liked a
more oxidized, medium oxidized
Tieguanyin, which is--
you hear it more
marketed as Iron Goddess.
And it's more brownside as
they let it oxidize a bit more.
These teas, I think arguably
it was the influence
of Taiwan moving--
Taiwan has always had the Li
Shan and other high mountain
Tieguanyin-style oolongs.
Theirs have always
been low-oxidized.
The world market was so
appreciative of that,
China's side mainland
started to really amp up
its production of
those years ago
to compete and get
some exposure as well,
gain some of that market.
So you saw a little
bit of movement
away from the medium
oxidized Tieguanyins.
This, that we won't taste
but I can certainly show you,
is Plum.
This is the Dan Cong style--
as you can see,
diametrically different.
It's a long leaf.
It's called Plum
Fragrance not because it's
been infused with anything.
There's nothing added to it.
It's just reminiscent of it.
The varietal reminds
people of plum.
It's very aromatic.
It's quite toasty,
almondy almost, in flavor.
And again, it's a
very high fire tea
that takes quite a
while to open and taste.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Ned, we talked
a little bit about it earlier.
But how do these
teas get their names?
NED HEAGERTY: That's always--
some are traditional, go
back to the beginning.
In some cases, locals
will name a tea.
In some cases, we have
applied names to them.
Drunken Concubine, of
course that's a name
we put to the Tieguanyin
for the US consumer.
We think it sort of makes it
more inviting, if you will.
It opens the door, if
you will, to this tea.
I can imagine trying to sell
Tian Mu Qing Ding in a grocery
store in Ohio
could be difficult.
It could be difficult
in San Francisco.
Heavenly Blue Peak,
on the other hand,
evokes some ahh,
something ethereal,
something a little more relaxed
and adventuresome, if you will.
So we're respectful of
that and mostly wanting
to get good tea into
people, into their lives.
I think one thing I
wanted to mention--
your asking that has reminded me
that one of the processes that
I think you use when you
buy tea and drink tea--
our minds have a
great ability when
we've tasted something really
good to recognize that.
And so when you're
buying tea, when
you know a taste
that you've liked,
and you're in the situation of
sampling tea or tasting tea,
you have that moment.
If you concentrate, you'll
pull back up that taste.
There it is.
And then you know
that's good tea.
And I know from my side,
that's incredibly important
because in a marketplace
environment trying to buy tea,
there's usually a lot
of things going on,
a lot of pressure to buy.
Let's make a deal.
And somehow or other, you've
got to pull up that resource
and remind.
But I've always been
impressed with our ability
to remember things we like.
And I think you apply that
in the process of buying tea,
and you will succeed.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for you.
You mentioned that
the plum scent was not
infused with plums.
But one of the
things that I've seen
is a lot of oolongs are
one of the ones that
are more flavored, like the
[INAUDIBLE] or the ginseng.
Do you do any of the
flavored oolongs?
NED HEAGERTY: No.
I mean we don't.
We've never ventured
into the flavored market.
As close as we come--
but I like to respond
to the opportunity.
And I have noticed, for
example, an interest
in white chrysanthemum being put
into a low-oxidized Tieguanyin.
That makes a wonderful taste.
Well, joining those two
naturals to create something,
yes, we do that.
We will blend.
But the additive market is--
I don't think we're
going to go there.
That's respectful
again of that--
I look at if the--
if we've done our
job, we've found
somebody who has taken a
tremendous amount of time
to cultivate and
manufacture a flavor.
And we go to China,
and we taste those.
And we say, this is good flavor.
This should come home.
And I want to--
as we say in Silk Road
Teas, we want to get out
of the way of the tea.
Let the tea come
through to the customer,
and they'll recognize.
So are we doing a second
steep on the Tieguanyin?
That's great.
I think I'm going to push us
because I know you guys want
to get back to work.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
NED HEAGERTY: This
is Black Fragrance.
On that theme again of China,
and respectful of the specialty
tea market and its individuality
and the small farm,
again, Mr. Wen in
his resourcefulness
made White Empress, Wild
Green, and Black Fragrance.
Same varietal, and
this tea is now black.
So it's fully oxidized.
Essentially, what he's
done is he's plucked it.
He's sorted it.
He's withered it.
He's then let it oxidize.
And then he's shaped it.
And then he's fired it.
But now it's black.
It's fully oxidized.
And the leaf has been
shaped to a certain extent.
And there's a little bit
of mix of bud in there,
but generally speaking just
high-grade top of the leaf
or the stem, bud,
and top two leaves.
Thank you.
Now you'll notice that I
am not measuring this out,
other than visually.
And that's purposeful
in the sense
that I really like to
try and demystify tea.
I'm very respectful of making
the best possible cup you can.
But I also don't
like to see people
agonize too much over
how much tea I'm using.
It's an exploration.
As I mentioned earlier, when
we're buying tea, we tend to--
if you would, there's
for the aroma.
You go through your process,
and you taste the teas
that you like.
And then as you
get to know a tea,
you begin to realize, I like it
at about this amount of time,
about this amount of leaf.
And you get that visual set up.
And that's the
exploration of tea
is finding that spot that's
your sweet spot that you enjoy.
And it's very easy.
So what I'm trying to do there
is somewhere around 3 grams.
That's a 7-ounce gaiwan.
Around 3 grams, but I'm
just doing it visually.
And I'm going to keep
the steep time probably
about a minute and
a half on this tea
because it is quite strong.
And I think at that
moment, my sense
is with tea that you're getting
the full flavor profile,
if you will.
Teas-- at that time,
there will be notes
that the tea maker
has left in the leaf
or accentuated in the leaf.
And those notes open early on.
The longer you steep a tea,
the more compacted the flavors
become.
Stronger flavors begin to
overwhelm lesser flavors.
So I recommend with
high-grade, specialty teas,
you keep your steep times
down so you get the range.
But of course, if you
like a lot of flavor
in the morning and a little
more punch, let it go.
But you ascertain that.
But relax about the quantities.
And you'll know when
you've put too much tea in.
I do it often, even in
these types of situations,
where I taste it, and
it's not the taste
I was hoping to give you.
But I think this will succeed.
So with the gaiwan, you can
encourage it like this also
to speed up in its process.
I think we can taste this.
It smells pretty good.
So fully-oxidized black
tea, of course, should--
if you like, that's a
very enjoyable aroma--
should be this kind of coppery
to red, which indicates
oxidization.
If it was a Yunnan red,
it would be bright red.
But this Mei Zhan
varietal, that's
the coppery sort
of reddish color
that it comes to
when it's steeped.
I think in this process,
the leaf is slow growing.
And so the processing
of the leaf
is actually quite delicate.
A little bit too
much temperature,
and it knocks its nice, sweet,
multi flavors into a bakey note
pretty quickly.
It's a fine line that the
tea maker has to maintain.
PAIGE SCHOENING: Thank you.
Yeah.
This is all really excellent.
Does anyone have
any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you have
an opinion on
where Europe stands
compared to the US in
appreciating green tea.
Do you see lots of traders--
I mean, traders from Europe--
competing for the same
specialty teas that you buy?
NED HEAGERTY: Yeah.
The Europeans--
PAIGE SCHOENING: Go ahead.
Let me repeat the
question real quick.
He was asking about kind of
how tea is in Europe, right?
AUDIENCE: Well, if it's the
same level of interest or more--
PAIGE SCHOENING: Right.
So if there's the same level
of interest in tea in Europe
as there is in other places.
NED HEAGERTY: Yeah.
I would venture, if it
was a race of some kind,
that Europe's a little
bit ahead of us.
I think certainly the
Germans and the Dutch
made early entry into China.
And they have great teas, yeah.
There is a high level of
interest in specialty teas.
Europe, though, is a
little bit like the US--
a lot of blends, frankly.
People have really taken
blending to another level.
And I think what we're seeing
is a little bit of that's
been sort of the tea model,
if you will, blended tea.
Everyone thinks,
this is really great.
We're seeing a little
bit of unbundling of that
and getting back
more to something
like this-- single origin,
nothing done to it.
Enjoy it as it is.
But Europeans definitely
I think appreciate tea,
have it more ingrained
in their culture.
So yeah, we're young
at tea, frankly,
in this country-- the Northeast
United States pretty active,
Southeast United States.
Out here, we're very active
in the greater Bay Area.
But it falls off precipitously
also in other areas.
But the specialty tea market
is growing dramatically
also in the United States.
PAIGE SCHOENING: So
the question was,
we drink a lot of
coffee in this office.
How do we encourage maybe
more people to drink tea?
NED HEAGERTY: There's a
few good reasons for that.
I think coffee's
sort of ingrained
for that startup in the morning.
I don't see us getting
around that other
than maybe a Pu-erh tea because
you can brew it very strong.
It looks like an espresso--
deep rich color, full-bodied.
And it makes you feel good.
I think the key for people
working during the day,
particularly who are in offices,
is that the caffeination in tea
mostly activates in
the mind, in the brain,
the hippocampus areas,
areas like that.
And you don't need
your body that much.
In fact, you'd like to
kind of hold it in reserve.
And so tea is very good at
stimulating mental activity.
It takes about seven hours
for the caffeine in tea
to work through.
But I think the
model that I promote
is, we're going to be a
coffee culture in the morning.
Great.
But once you're here, and you're
settled down, and you're good,
you're working, oolong
tea or other teas
are very much more refreshing
and stimulating for the mind.
They also go better with food.
It's not so obstructive of
food, much less acidity.
And you've got health
benefits, of course.
You can always
market to the health.
But I think for
practicality's sake,
if people get in the
rhythm of a little coffee
and then maybe
transition a little tea
or maybe a little
mix of the two--
but tea can really
be very beneficial
just in allowing you to
think clearly and not
have to wear your body
out at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
NED HEAGERTY: Thank you.
PAIGE SCHOENING:
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate
having you, so thank you.
NED HEAGERTY: Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]